[Musique]
hum
pour commencer on n'est pas reçue cdi
avec le professeur d'arts plastiques
mangou glof on a fait des recherches
on a vu ce qui s'est passé pendant la
guerre la fit et sauve a été atroce avec
le dessin avec la colombie sans briser
la paix le coeur c'était pour symboliser
l'amitié entre les deux pays d'un côté
fini des éléments qui représente la
france et de l'autre vous montez
représente l'allemagne et le drapeau
l'hymne à perdre pour représenter le
taux des pays oui c'est important de se
rappeler tout ce qui s'est passé ça vous
a pas oublié ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé on a eu beaucoup de choses
on a vu les conditions de vie
des
costumes on va dire on a vu aussi des
pas qui avait on a vu des tranchées
c'était difficile parce que vous n'avez
pas des conditions faciles comme nous
aujourd'hui majeur présenté une femme
qui souffle et quand elle se souvient
des oiseaux qui se forment ensuite
j'écris liberté paix amitié et après
j'ai mis du vent enfin les feuilles qui
s'envole on a fait des recherches cdi on
a fait une carte heuristique pour
regrouper toutes nos idées
sélectionner les meilleurs et puis on a
fait une sortie hors ce menu leur kop
pour pour se renseigner
et parler un peu de la voix pour
l'amitié j'ai mis une alsacienne tient
un drapeau de de l'europe avec les
étoiles france et allemagne ça touche un
peu de voir comment quand les personnes
ont vécu la première guerre parce que là
il y avait des conditions pas forcément
favorable il faut continuer à en parler
parce que c'est important que que les
jeunes sachent ce que la génération
d'avant elle a vécu on a vu le musée
donc l'historial et après on a visité
allait trancher tout ça bah c'était des
conditions rudes et avait fait
il n'avait pas beaucoup à manger
là on peut voir donc c'est le drapeau de
l'allemagne la drapeau de la france donc
là il ya un métier liberté père il ya
les mêmes mots ici en allemand il ya des
colons pour représenter la paix et puis
demain qui se bat qui tiennent la main
pour représenter l'amitié entre
l'allemagne et la france que tu qu'on a
appris plein de choses on en est en lui
et artois une valeur coop et puis c'est
bien de participer des fois des concours
donc c'est une bien c'est grâce à mes
deux chats ce que j'en ai deux
et du coup ça m'est venu l'idée de
dessiné pour ce qu'ils sont amis cet ep
qui se bagarrent qui
c'est important d'en parler parce que
c'était avant nous et
s'ils auraient que de l'amitié partout
où il y aurait pas d hier
c'est quelque chose qui est venu comme
ça
ça me faisait penser à l'amitié et la
liberté ce qu'ils étaient dans un
concours
bah moi ça me fait un peu penser à
des enfants qui que sandro qui se
prennent ensemble avec un fond
chlorés donc qui veut représenter un peu
l'univers de la liberté est en tête qui
sont dans une main qui forme à un coeur
et ça va vous présenter en fait la paix
malgré qu'on soit tout différent il faut
s'aimer il faut vivre dans un monde où
il faut apprendre à bien vivre ensemble
alors en fait j'ai eu l'idée déjà d'un
bougeoir
g
ni de couleurs d'automne pour pour
symboliser l'automne parce qu'on était
en période automne ben je suis très
contente parce que je pensais pas du
tout avoir gagné on peut tous s'entendre
conçoit allemand qu'on soit français
qu'on soit d'une autre langue qu'on soit
différent de pau
bonne année à tous meilleurs
à une route à sir conan et meilleurs
voeux à tous à une bouteille à bonal et
meilleurs voeux à tous à une goûteuse ce
noyau siar